façon pour la merci merci c'est pour
être sûr que non nous entendons qu'alors
je vais juste et monsieur doit arrêter
la musique je sais pas si vous
l'entendez ou pas monsieur pénitents
voilà mon jeu est arrêté
voilà donc la musique d'ailleurs
connaître la musique de régis vaughn
line appel à maître voilà alors que la
deuxième partie de ce match commence la
revanche est la revanche entre alberto
david et yoann benita voilà donc dans
cette première partie je te demanderai
de s'il vous plaît 2 voilà c'est parti
voilà le 4d 4 donc c'est une défense
française caractérisée ici après le coup
4,6 par les noirs voilà des 4 et si les
noirs donc ont laissé des bancs
installés une phalange de pions ici
centrale et contre attaque
ici le centre avec ici le pion le pion
des quatre voilà faut 3
a été joué donc les blancs essayé de
tenir le pion des quatre câbles et c6
les blancs en continu les noirs pendant
continue de faire pression ici sur le
pion des quatre dans cette défense
française car il ya quatre étaient
jouées par les blancs damas cinq échecs
c'est trois ou à la b4 ça va vite
tout ça est très connue des joueurs dans
ce qu'on appelle la théorie dame b 5
voilà ici les blancs une belle phalange
de pions ici avec un pion aux scènes
très forts vents soutenus par des 4es
par f4 voilà alors je sais pas si on
monte un mais j'aimerais qu'on fasse
moins de bruit dans l'accueil du théâtre
fémina merci pendant que nous commentons
c'est parti ici cavaliers aux 7,1 a été
jouée par à yoann benita faut 2 les
cours eux continuent donc là les blancs
on peut réussir à jouer les fondamentaux
de cette de cette défense la défense
française en ayant une belle flanche de
pions ici c'est 3 des 4 5
la base de cette structure étant le pion
c3 qui paraît difficilement attaquable
par les noirs puisqu'il n'ya pas de
colonne ici qui permettrait de l'attaqué
le pion c4d noir faisant office de
bouchons donc une phalange qui sera
quasiment impossible à a cassé entre
partis et noir à l'exception c4 contrôle
bien la case d3 dans le camp des blancs
aussi
voilà où ils ont même une belle lignée
de pions alors souvent dans ce type de
structure les blancs ont joué dans
contre cette structure de pions en
jouant des plans à base de g4 et ensuite
f5 en préparant évidemment cette cette
poussée
mais c'est souvent l'idée qui est joué
voilà donc cavalier h 6
vient d'être jouée par johan benita
attaquant le pion g4 ici donc le
cavalier ici attaque le pion donc on est
dans une partie de manoeuvre tour g1
maintenant donc décidément c'est une
manie puisque les blancs là maintenant
quand tout à l'heure le johann benita
s'était enlevé la possibilité du grand
roque en jouant le coup vous rappelez il
avait joué le contour c1 est bien ici
maintenant seul coûte tour g1 qui a été
jouée par alberto david et qui s'enlève
de la possibilité de jouer petit rock
donc on va laisser là aussi le roi au
centre ces caractéristiques que des de
ces deux partis qu'on vient de voir où
effectivement il s'agit de ne de partie
où on laisse les blancs prendre le
centre ici par les cases des 4 5 lés
blandford force entre qui ont des quatre
pions et 5
les noires n'ayant qu'un seul pion au
centre de pions des 5 alors que dans la
première partie c'était aussi donc cette
défense est indienne où les blancs avec
un centre encore plus fort contrôlé à
distance par les noirs alors j'aimerais
qu'on
voilà juste vous pouvez signaler un
accueil d'arrêter de faire du bruit
pendant les parties
dams et 6
voilà que oui là moi je
je reviens à la partie donc dans cet
effet se rouvrent française je découvre
une française variante davance c'est ça
voilà donc vendent avance effectivement
avec donc deux structures comme je
disais cette fameuse d'accord ici très
solide de la part des blancs et donc
pour le du côté noir cette structure ici
et 7,6 des 5 c 4
voilà il est les blancs vont tout faire
pour bourgeois f5 quinze jours c'est à
dire la tacc l'attaquent de chaînes
thématiques
voilà de jouer c'est ce que j'ai signalé
tout à l'heure et finalement c'est
exactement le plan que j'avais signalé
j'ai 4 et 5 mais on ne peut pas le faire
on peut pas le faire dira évidemment
donc il faut préparer s'organiser
d'abord touché 1 pour protéger le thon
g4 qui est attaqué par le cavalier 6
évidemment là pour l'instant s inquiète
pas possible puisque les noirs attaque
avec l'upe 06 avec le caillage 6 et
aussi le fou ces huit en transparence
qui contrôle très bien cette case f5
voilà alors le dernier coup alors qu'est
ce qui se passe là avec ce dernier could
alberto david que je ne comprends pas
car il y avait 3 5 mai trois bains
scipion prend b3 il y aura foule b5 avec
gan la dame s'est ainsi va le montrer ce
dos la crise
le fousseret venu sur la case médecin
qui on voit que la dame c6 aurait subi
un clouage est une combinaison le roi
est leur pop bouger et donc elle était
perdue
d'abord été gardé c'est ce qu'on appelle
un pseudo sacrifice voilà il ne pouvait
pas être pris quoi les noirs ne sont pas
tombés dans le piège
voilà c'était
ça peut être surpris aussi yoann benita
mais metz a permis en fait je recycle
aux cavaliers de revenir en vie parce
que après b 6 il aurait eu des petits
problèmes sont pas si si le plus de gaz
pour revenir
il avait plus de cases donc grâce à ce
petit stratagème pas le montrer en
cavalier mais plus de 15 depuis la casse
bessette louis lacaze reid lcd prise par
le pouce et 8 à 15 17 et moi si la crise
au cices aussi la case quatre prix par
le plan des 5 voilà il restait les case
d3 et b3 et il était un cercle est il
était encerclé donc il fallait profiter
de cette menace
voilà ici pour sortir le cavalier de 7,2
ce ce piège ce pion les espagnols disent
la bestia est à broder ada est la bête
était cerné c'est ouais voilà oui
d'accord donc à cinq a été jouée suivi
deux baies 5 donc les blancs en
stabilisé les dames plus de rupture
possible par les noirs sur la dame
sauf sauf si les filles sauf dynamitage
sacrifices c'est à dire ceux d'orly une
pièce pour deux pions à tous que ça
dynamitage oui c'est à dire ont fait
exploser la structure de pions en ont
une ou deux pièces
alors bien sûr
ce type de position a un intérêt c'est
que dans les finales on peut donner une
pièce pour deux pions et avoir les pions
en débordant qui courent sur l'ale dame
équivalent quelquefois une pièce
quelques fois mais attention évidemment
à lorsque tous les cours ce que tu
disais effectivement euros nous c'est
que ça c'est important stratégiquement
une partie très stratégique il ya encore
un seul échange que ce soit de pions ou
deux pièces
voilà donc d'un côté c'est verrouillé de
ce côté là il ya plus de possibilités
pour les noirs de casser avec des pions
on voit bien ce pion peu juste quand
l'art et 6 et de l'autre côté par contre
les blancs aime toujours cette avancée
f5 possible d'ordonner à priori un léger
avantage
comme d'habitude le joueur le mieux
classé organise le mieux sans sa
réflexion et ses pièces et donc là il va
essayer d'imposer la pousse et ça vous
sert à rien quand on a parlé tout à
l'heure la colonne f donc l'idée de fous
j'ai trois ça peut être aussi pourquoi
pas plus tard de m la tour en f1 afin de
protéger cette poussée f5 et
éventuellement même de pénétrer plus
tard sur cette colonne f
voilà le plan que l'on s'attend à trois
là ben il faudra aussi peut-être qui
s'engage à transférer sans roi cdma
notre relationnel dame donc live à
manoeuvrer
alors là cavalier fin est logique parce
qu'on veut venir en 3 protégeant
toujours une fois la case et cinq jours
pour se mettre alors à l'ex-régie tout
de suite l'avouer ça y est il n'attend
même pas que ça se fasse
melita choisit maintenant lui même de
pousser f5 avec la menace si les banques
font rien de juger si ce sans doute vont
dérouiller
alors c'est un coup très intéressant
parce que le roi blanc est resté au
centre et que le blanc peut
difficilement se permettre de prendre un
passant à la fameuse prise en passant si
on prend le ski ont eu 5 pourrait
prendre le pion f sur la case f6 le qui
l'affranchît arrêterait voilà il y en
aurait repris avec le pion j'adore ça
s'appelle la prise en passant les
enfants sincère le coup d'après quand un
pion joue de deux cases voilà considérer
qu'il a bougé encore que d'une que d'une
et en réception voilà c'est la fameuse
compensation qui avait été inventé
à l'époque où on avait dynamisé le jeu
d'échecs en permettant aux pions
d'avancé de 15 ans et viols qui est là
cette option alberto david y joue comme
cali ou 3 bien sûr il nation soit là il
ne prend pas 9,6 parce que les
ouvertures au centre aurait été sans
doute est très critique pour sao cercle
et reprendre le projet puis ouvrir les
lignes et ouvrir les nids par f5
profitable et de leur centre aideront
les problèmes donc la prise en passant
était interdite
donc il faut s'orienter vers autre chose
donc pression sur f5 et en même temps
les blancs on sent tout dans l'idée de
faire jouer cette fois non plus sur le
col de neef comme prévu initialement
mais maintenant sur la colonne g et
prendre au bon moment f5
pourquoi pas
le dernier coup d'oeil ou de melita
cavaliers g6 petite pression sur f4 elle
est défendue que par le fou alors
imaginez qu'une tour renault viennent en
effet oui et menaces pions problème 5 et
le pion aux quatre tombes et puis aussi
sur sur pire il faut voir que sur pied
on prend f5 et cavalier noir pro f 5 ans
les blancs ont la possibilité de jouer
cavalier prend f5 et de se retrouver
avec un pion passé qui on le sait est
passé de 5 soutenu par les deux autres
clients ce qui en général est une force
pour la finale donc il peut très bien
choisir alberto david de prendre
maintenant
en effe sec puisque les noirs n'ont pas
choisi la défense passive g6 pour
consolider f5 mais plutôt qu'avec les
j-6 qui contre attaque sur le pion f40
fait une petite pression aussi alors je
suppose que l'idée de cavaliers g6 c'est
peut-être de laisser prendre en 9,5 de
manière à à plus tard ramener lecavalier
9 8 puis sur la case de 6 pour bloquer
le fameux pions passé 5 et en même temps
ce cavalier ci servirait à attaquer le
pion f4 à faire pression sur des 4 etc
sera noté qu'au temps alors que david
est quand même 11 minutes contre 16,1
donc là il a pris quand même beaucoup de
temps de réflexion
dans cette deuxième partie alors
deuxième partie cruciale à 1 renault
puisque donc après sa première partie au
nul qui est un bon résultat pour alberto
david le favori de ce match aller il a
fait nul avec les pièces noires effet
nude avec les noirs donc maintenant il
peut essayer donc de gagner c'est ce
qu'il essaie de faire avec les blancs
alors en cas de match nul sur cette
deuxième partie bien nous aurons droit
tout de suite un sens sans interruption
nous aurons droit à deux blitz de
départage en libye se sont départis de
cinq minutes par un éboueur alors et que
se passe-t-il si là encore match nul au
goût des deux litres alors nouvelle
partie donc cette fois il y aura un
troisième blitz 1,8 ce qu'on appelle
mort subite renault ou là les blancs en
cinq minutes les noirs
4 et et mais par contre obligations
obligation de gagner pour les blancs
avec leurs minutes supplémentaires voilà
qu'on peut très bien gagner un match
finalement faisant que des nuls en
faisant que des nuls oui c'est de
terminer avec la dernière partie nulle
et gagner le match
alors c'est un peu comme ça d'ailleurs
que karpov avait gagné le grand prix les
d'abel éliminant ben ari sebag c'est ça
où il avait éliminé marie ce blog au
premier tour mais il avait surtout été
poussé au blitz lovely de voir
subitement s'est mis avec hicham chasse
haïtien très grande finale que hicham
avait dominé puisqu'il avait mené au
score dans les parties rapides et et
oublient de soucis et ça s'était joué en
mort subite
je crois qu'il avait gagné le blitz
puisque en bouche il devait gagner avec
les bleus en fait été un peu joué son va
tout voilà donc g5 quatrième set et
maintenant voilà le blocage que veulent
jouer il ya décidément il c'est un fan
de déblocage et un run by dita c'est son
truc à elle c'est moi qui le dit qu' il
en avoir sa chance en partie rapide donc
ce que ça risque pas donc qu'il est il
veut essayer de yb essayer de faire une
nulle là il voulait que tout soit
bloquée et puis voyez me bloquer tout ça
je pense que s'il veut gagner ici
mais à viesly doit refuser mes roulés
joie et doit prendre patience est pas
une erreur s'il est blanc joue par
exemple le coût cumulé des deux qu'est
ce qui se passe avec dame est fou qui
attaquent le pion h5 comment je défends
ce pion bas ils le défendent pas mais il
quand on attaquera sur le pian achi
jours à tour h7 puis prend attaque le
cavalier oui d'accord d'accord chaud
quand même un we show peut-être il
pourra il le fait il le fait alberto il
le fait c'est à dire il est habile à
jouer cavalier va lier les deux
qu'est-ce qui se passe d'accord ils
pensent qu'ils je pense que les noirs
semblent prêts à donner un pion pour
avoir la compensation sur la sur la
colonne jeu contre attaquer sur cette
contre attaque est sur le pied en
attention on a aussi les blancs ont le
temps de prendre un f5 puis de jouer
acheter de joueurs c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de contraintes avait classé les
blancs qui sont mieux on va jouer pour
acheter ensuite
d'ailleurs on voit bien que les blancs
monts même le temps de protéger selon h4
le problème c'est que il ya le cahier g6
et le cavalier recettes qui sont
attaqués oui mais va peut-être pouvoir
jouer que font les noirs peut-être
pouvoir jouer cavalier à on va quand les
sentiments là que hilali a fuité puis
j'ai six peut-être a prévu ce simple
coup m cavaliers 8-6 et un jour ou
l'autre il prend il récupérera son pion
à chaud - il fera pression dessus
alors attention tant au sirop non oui
puisqu'on n'a pas fini de 10 contre
15,15 pour les noirs là c'est une belle
avance
c'est la partie précédente que alberto
même si qu'il a finit par paraître moins
bien sur l'échiquier
je sais à perdre en bio mais il avait
tellement d'avancé autant que finalement
elle a réussi à équilibrer oui oui la
partie voilà fou 8
voilà alors l'idée de fond 8 évidemment
braunau c'est d'avoir une défense n
direct du curage 5 à travers ans par
transparence en quelque sort reste c'est
à dire qu'il va peut-être je pense qu'il
va peut-être donner une qualité tout
sacrifié sur fou princes 5 qui peut
peut-être joué tout reproche 5 suivi de
cavaliers prendrait way sans doute
peut-être peut-être c'est possible c'est
pas clair c'est pas clair c'est possible
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il a vu mais je
crois que tout simplement pour nous il a
vu plus loin effectivement il va neiger
pression que là où la bertauge joue très
vite soukhoum et moi j'ai très peur du
coup cavalli prendre 5 alors j'explique
si les blancs prennent du plomb des ja
d'apprendre cavaliers de 3 et si on
prend du plomb ayant m
eh bien on peut le reprendre en cinq ans
il le fait il fait d'abord en effet
d'abord tu auras la rai prend un f4
c'est un peu pareil et c'est un peu
pareil de toute façon les blancs vont
être obligés de reprendre les cavaliers
et fait venir en 5 et le fou huit
attaques la dame en même temps oui
aïe le fait aulas est terrible c'est fx
qui cependant que raison puisque
maintenant des cas validé trois jets
donc il a donné une qualité ils reculent
aussi
il a donné une qualité
oui voilà il a donné une qualité pour
ouvrir les lignes ce qu'alberto devine
vite ils essaient de combinaisons il
sait préserver ce qu'on appelle la
carrière ce que les russes appelé ce
qu'on appelait autrefois la qualité
soviétique c'est à dire on a un petit
souci dit voilà c'est à dire qu'on a
donné une qualité mais en compensation
c'est préserver la paire de fou et pour
les noirs ouais il va récupérer le fou
un f4 la tac boum
avec un centre aérien
alors ce qui est très intéressant dans
les sacrifices de qualité c'est que très
souvent les les fous dans une position
ouverte ballet l'échiquier et donc
compenser largement la qualité sur un
des magistrats surtout quand il appert
de foule dans le cavalier des trois
échecs
il comprend le plonger cette voie là
donc ils récupèrent plus est donc alors
petit bilan matériel après cette
combinaison époustouflante de la part
des deux joueurs
donc là j'ai eu quand même une prise de
risque maximale des deux côtés j'ai
envie de dire oui
donc il ya deux pièces ici ailleurs deux
cavaliers on va dire c'est une qualité
net
voilà c'est une qualité net pour les
blancs mes qualités dans cedar une tour
contre une pièce mineurs rien puisque
cette tour là est compensé par la tour 1
mais la fameuse qualité soviétique donc
les deux fous pour la quand même les
deux fous et de fo pour la tour par
contre il ya deux pions pas s'il est il
ya deux magnifiques qui ont passé lié
donc alors attention c'est compliqué
d'estimé
cette position alors c'est celle là
était l'intérêt des positions
déséquilibre est fou c'est qu'elles sont
difficiles à juger quand je compare à la
dure oui alors évidemment l'idée sur
dame prend et futurs la nba ça ça
combine de partout pour nous dans ces
partis sur de premières fuites
évidemment il y avait foule cinq échecs
au grand oui
viendraient ensuite tout reprend dame
une fois que l'échec était paré donc il
fallait surtout pas prendre le fou même
si ce fou semblait non défendu ça va
vite ça va c'est quand même beaucoup de
combinaisons c'est ça va très vite la
label état est dans son élément
opposition déséquilibrée
attaque sur le roi la paire de fou qui
compense la qualité voilà et david lui
va essayer de valoriser ses pions passé
qui ont passé il veut sans oublier david
très vite jouée g6 très vite essayer de
g6 menace d'un prend ensuite parce que
maintenant il y aura plus échec de
menacer la promotion pour l'instant
c'est pas lui de jouer donc là tu as
même s'il garde un oeil sur ie6 oui
menace par exemple cavaliers prend f5
il peut me lasser qu'à l'épreuve 5
effectivement au nom puisque six jours
qu'il comprend et bien là la dame l6
prendre la dame b6 donc échec 5 3 ans et
2 passes et 2 voilà comment on fait une
petite échec ici peut-être que les noirs
veulent alors les bons solide et angers
oui et l'ailé noire les noirs aimerait
que ses pions centraux n'existe pas si
les pièces entre n'existait pas leur
père de fou sauver terrible et pour
l'instant leur père de foule ne peut pas
vraiment de tirer tout c'est à dire que
c'est super de fous ici ne peut pas
s'exprimer pour aller encore beaucoup de
pions qui les gêne voilà voilà
c'est vrai qu'ils sont pas à plein
régime en cours c'est fou mais ils
peuvent le à tout moment il pourrait y
avoir des ruptures centrale c'est pas
qui pourrait permettre de casser d'oeufs
cassés tout ça oui
tradition et côté droit ces deux joué
alors regardez comme alberto david
épanché sur son échiquier la tête entre
les mains laquelle concentration
terrible d'alberto david voilà benita
qu'avais-je et si ça n'était joue
cavalier g6 pour bloquer les pions les
pions passé lié les deux pions sont
bloqués pour l'instant cavalli prend f5
alors ça y est il le souhaitait le
concours a vu que j'avais prévu d'en
parler puisque que tu avais prévu très
fort coup est ce que il aurait
sous-estimé ce qu'on dames c'est cette
approche et aulas a fait ça y est ça y
est là je crois que la femme était
confiant eh bien je crois comme deux
couillons de bélie tape a prévu le coup
car il excelle il a oublié un qu'il a
oublié à oublier cavaliers bref ces
derniers ce coup et après dames et chez
qui les jours au but 8
voilà mais ça maintenant ça sent très
compromis parce que quand même ça fait
les pions perdu d'un coup là mais oui à
moins que ce soit voulu pour ouvrir les
lignes
peut-être qu'il veut jouer ensuite le
coup cavaliers f4 attaquant la dame
suivie de fou g6 qui clouerait
lecavalier f 5 et 6 vient d'être jouée
par liberto david voilà je crois que là
c'est ça va être terrible
point de benita combes et 6
quand même un coût extrêmement puissant
où va la dame comme si la dame dit en f4
elle va être attaqué ici par la deuxième
tour peut-être et elle a pas beaucoup de
cases à sa disposition
ou alors on viendrait d'un cervicales à
cette dame pourrait venir éventuellement
sur la case h 2 et sinon il y aurait eu
plus que la case h7 aulas est venu se
maintient
y'a quand même le cas et c'est sur la
route et le roi derrière voilà donc une
dame quand même qui ramasse un petit peu
des petites choses donc dès que le
cavalier g6 joue il y à déployer ce
qu'on appelle les cobras c'est pour ça
qu'ils enlèvent le roi tout simplement
alberto il a une position gagnante elle
est partout david je crois il a
maintenant sa position est ce que là la
perte de ses deux pions coup sur coup
n'était pas prévu alors la cavalière 4
alors à noter c'est le problème du roi
b2c caprica et f4 qu'elle va pouvoir
faire encore en échec sur le web et 2
qui va devoir venir en a deux oui mais
et en attendant on va la dame blanche
peut-être un petit échec
ab non un petit échec serait pas bon
renault parce qu'on ferait un échec bien
sûr mais quand le roi bouge ça enlève
non seulement ça enlève pas la menace
câble échec mais en plus ça mais la dame
sur la fourchette mais c'est à dire
qu'un peu ça serait peut-être pas mal
alors bizarrement sur damas un qui
pourrait le paraît par fou des six tours
il parlait parfois des six parce que sur
cavale et prend des six eh bien on fait
la fourche échec et gagné 1 d'avant la
dame bien violente qui va pas faire
échec qui va bouger ça d'abord là ils
attaquent la pièce en l'air la torah m6
il attaque la tour à tour des huit dents
depuis m6 il attaque la tour des huit
cavaliers detroit cheikh quitte échec
pour mettre le cavaliere abri aussi la
wii on le protège par le pion à
développions onu le roi venir à deux
puisque le fou regarde et le fou ces
huit protéger et à huy au bon moment il
protège la tour et autres attaques
ciblées sur le pion à quatre aux jeux
comme en défense et te voilà lorsqu'on
va jouer roi b1 simplement
alors pourquoi on n'a pas joué tout de
suite roye b 1 maintenant le joug témoin
l'a ensuite parce que tout à l'heure il
y avait il y avait sept
quand même cette grande menace ici cette
diagonale oui la dame était à nice c'est
tout à l'heure il y aurait pu avoir une
découverte n'aurait pu y avoir une
découverte nos petites combines bien
observer la est obligé de jouer deux
fois le roi ça fait quand même beaucoup
de coup droit pour le ver taux d'avis
dans le roi se promènent non mais sauvé
au conseil de sécurité il ya la paire de
fou qui est toujours là quand vous le
tour lent vivant c'est tout donc on va
dire avantage pour les blancs mais pour
l'instant dynamisme au moins
l'initiative au noir un peu comment
faire rentrer les pièces noires comment
faire entrer les pièces noires donc
c'est le problème de yoann benita qui
doit absolument arracher le nul au moins
pour rester dans le grand prix ouais et
alors peut-être jouer éventuellement des
départage peut-être truites pour faire
rentrer cette tour alors à noter
qu'alberto david est comme ça sur la
seconde de ranger un peu habitué
maintenant des grands prix même s'il n'a
pas encore joué le petit bordeaux
l'an dernier non il n'a pas joué l'an
dernier donc il n'a pas encore joué mais
il avait joué le grand prix des chèques
d'aix-en-provence où il avait terminé 4e
c'est ma maman est bonne il avait perdu
les départage face à joseph sanchez un
grand prix qui avait été gagné par
laurent frayssinet voilà pourtant
apprend qu'elle va les prendre tous
reprend simplification la halle
avantages qu'il ya eu évidemment des
blancs petite menace de maths menace
tourbe et de maths en passage up tour b1
pour parer et la tour s'en va j'ai eu
des simplifications à 6 et noir ont
choisi de simplifier et noir c'est noir
qui ont choisi de simplifier
ça va vite donc 4 minutes 30 pour les
blancs contre une minute trente pour les
noirs donc il ya une simplification
voulue par les noirs avec le couffo et
suite aux 6-10 6 par des échanges
général sur la case des six est
maintenant l'oncle et noir ont une
réalité les pires de retard qualité net
de moins d'un gros avantage blanc quand
même gros avantage blanc une tour est
quand même bien supérieur un cavalier
futile en d3 oui mais bon bref il ya des
choses encore évidemment un coût comme
toro 2 toujours embêtant même si bon
c'est qu'avec des deux va être difficile
à déloger ce que celui-ci de cases
blanches
je pense que sur tours de le pion
marcherait sa route là bas pour g6 car
monsieur en session jouer le hacker est
logée la plongée c'est la mare plate et
derrière derrière le pion bien sûr mais
surtour blanche qui cenap qui pousse son
pion le fameux vent du sud qui pousse
alors le dernier clame qui envers la
promotion du nber dit à tour 6 quasiment
forcé puisque l'échangé les tours ont
été un aveu de quasiment un aveu de deux
défaites
quelle partie quel partisan d'une quand
même alors donc il ya eu 7 cette erreur
sans doute peut-être là le coutour b5
on l'a oublié ce coup cavalli pro f 5
alors qu'il semblait que les noirs
avaient quand même réussi à bien contrer
la perte du pin sec et mais peut-être à
s'est un peu emmêlé les pinceaux et
yoann benita dans la suite des éléments
peut-être joué un peu trop vite alors
qu'il a un gros avantage autant commun
qui peut jouer sur la fin de partie pour
y revenir grâce à cet avantage autant
même si techniquement quand même on a
quand même le sentiment qu'un grand
maître de la classe dabernat berthod
david quand même qui a gagné deux fois
en championnat de paris qui convergent
et d un gros trop je ferais d'art y en
avait des gros joueurs
donc là il vient de jouer tour tour gf1
menace d'envahir d'envahir la 6e et
lorraine joueurs voudront aussi this
pour pousser g6 pour pousser g6 pour
menacer de charger la tour pour il ya
aussi le coutour f5 qui plane pour
attaquer deux fois le le pion des cinq
cantons 25 tours b c'est là en jour et
web 5 dans un premier temps puis tomber
c'est notre temps pour attaquer cette
faiblesse donc pour bouffer le pion là
les tours et ainsi sociaux tandis que
ces cas là seraient attaqués par le
cavalier or là on perd là ça serait un
désastre c'est possible que les blancs
choisissent de jouer comme ça tellement
main ou la torah des colonnes pour
s'exprimer
la qualité la qualité et remonte ses
avantages voilà très joli coup ce petit
couteau f1 oui ou d'activation de pièces
et la loi novelli ta vie un moment
difficile
elle aurait peut-être dû jouer sur son
capital temps ici ces sept minutes là
peut-être quand il a joué cette grande
semaine cette grosse combinaison
centrale alors rappelez vous la il a
laissé le pillage 5 il a fait des
sacrifices cavalaire très prometteur en
il ya peut-être pu en tirer quelque
chose de mieux
voilà donc
les changes va parler au 19e siècle on
appelait les changes gagner les changes
on disait quand on gagne et une pièce
mineurs contre une tour ou une tour
contre une pièce mineurs détenus sont
joués on disait gagner les changes est
d'ailleurs les américains continuent à
appeler ça avec exchange gagner la
qualité d'accord c'est qu'ils étaient du
vieux français gagner les changes
on avait des charges en sa faveur
peut-être un coup comme jeu officiel
renault puis tout à l'heure j'ai
réfléchi un coup comme fou g6 tout
simplement qui quand même menace une
petite découverte met donc tour 2 voilà
pour deux à tomber 6 à peut-être encore
plus précis que ton que coûte à proposer
peut-être il veut jouer le coup tout âge
6 on a activé cette tourbe est un pays
peut aussi menacé tour des six
simplement pour gagner la ligue en échec
ont gagné le pion des 5 pour prendre là
il roule la vie rend la qualité et
pourquoi
iran la qualité agenda la nouvelle st
pierre ou mal fou fou 2 à detroit
attention détroit est celle qu'on voit
le roi 3 b2 et le cavalier va avoir des
soucis après tour de wayne ou g6 les
pian passé sont une force foulée a joué
pour deux tours de away me va faire dame
d'accord autour d'eux
tour g1 est ce qu'il n'a pas joué un peu
il joue un peu vite j'ai l'impression là
maintenant c'est les pieds en sang mais
attention à tout ce qui se passe sur
trou j'ai deux renault parce que voilà
le cavalier et emprises moi c'est un
échec au roi gab2 tours 2-2 et oui mais
ce qui l'aurait pas jouer plus vite
alberto da bin là il va être obligé de
donner ce cavalier semble-t-il et il
n'avait peut-être pas prévu ça et ouais
ça va être nulle part répétition
apparemment et oui signé par une
émission incroyable al alawi d'astuces
il a trouvé une astuce superbe pour
lutter cette intimité de ses pièces
qu'on va voir bliss tout de suite il n'y
a pas de dire ça ne causerait pas de
pause
il faut un vrai faux ap les joueurs n'y
a pas de pause il n'y a pas de pause
julien si tu peux appeler les joueurs
remercient nous allons aller à l'eau
j'ai bien dû m'entendre sévit depuis
julien dumond peut appeler les joueurs
d'une suite de joueurs on y va tout de
suite tout de suite voilà faut pas que
les joueurs repartent
tant pis ils sont repartis donc le blanc
l'a mal négocié sans qu'on va avoir un
avantage roi au blitz tout de suite
alors que j'attends que julien à mettre
les choses en place
le belle remontée lors mais décidément
là on a le droit d être doublée de béni
taki qui était plutôt mal dans cette
position malela alberto d'avis de jouer
un peu vite à semble-t-il un parti dans
la phase technique dans la phase
technique il a mélangé les pinceaux
il va il aurait dû simplifier faire des
échanges avant de de chercher à tout
prix à valoriser ses pions il aurait dû
simplifier
alors je vous ricol oui la position
[Musique]
voilà finale qui font pas taper dans le
mythe rôle à un micro sans téléphone
portable c'est payant alors qu'on va
rappeler les joueurs voilà pour cette
alors je suis pas sûr que ce soit mais
dit à david
c'est plutôt l'inversé d'ailleurs ans
plus tôt david benita je crois en elles
arbitres mais il me semble que j'ai dit
a démarré avec les blancs donc pour les
départage celle inverse et l'intention
nous allons attention julien avec
l'arbitré voilà un salon et versez-la
début du match par rapport à tout à
l'heure vous souvenez que c'était
monsieur benita qu'avec mon champ avec
les blancs voient la consommation d'eau
vides
donc c'est ça a l'air donc attention ça
va être nemisz pour gagner la partie des
partages messieurs on est parfois là
donc c'est parti voilà c'est parti donc
nouvelles françaises
on joue la même variante est oui
attention qu'à préparer ces deux on voit
que c'est toujours très bien préparés
pour apparemment ils ont tout prévu
connaissent bien leurs débuts extrait
bien leurs débuts les quatre dames b5 et
je vous la même qui voulait b5 cavaliers
de cette même variante que total air il
faut deux cas les f-5 wave 2 c'est un
peu la même variante vous rappelez un
donc ça va aller beaucoup plus vite sans
doute là sur le sur le 8 mai l'idée
c'était toujours de jouer f4 f5
je vais me remettre en verre
on est mieux habillés en vert un mot non
je vais faire donc un match passionnant
décidément la ceb d'état qui crée la
surprise en annulant ces deux parties
face à alberto david favori de ce match
labarthe david qui est rappelons-le et
grand maître international et a déjà eu
deux mille six cents lots donc il a fait
partie des 100 meilleurs mondiaux
alors que yohann benita est un maître
international
donc est ce qu'on va dire semi amateurs
oui mais quand tu es là non je pense
qu'ils qui se professionnalise de plus
en plus donc j'ai en tout cas mais
vainqueur de virer comme un amateur
vainqueur de l'open des veines naujac
comme quoi hein en gironde on fait des
tournois où il ya des beaux vainqueurs
aussi des grands joueurs âgés 3h 3 donc
sept minutes 4 minutes pour albert david
quatre minutes pour yoann benita donc
c'est la première partie de deux cd
partage donc décidément les joueurs
n'ont pas réussi à départager pour
l'instant damas quatre propositions ici
des changes de dames alors que à
signaler que le match suivant on verra
s'affronter laurent frayssinet grand
favori de ce grand prix 2007 avec hicham
hamdouchi verra affronter au loin fait
signer avec le champion d'aquitaine 2006
donc le jeune et donc pas franck hargot
qui finalement ne peut pas venir mais ça
sera la raque eu lieu avec le champion
d'aquitaine de l'année précédente
donc échangeons et charlie et m
marc lévesque purs amateurs très bon
niveau parce qu'il ya 2200 hello je
crois bien sûr donc échange du fou de
cases blanches et 5 et on se retrouve
avec une structure bloqué au centre le
pion à 4 très important pour éviter que
les blancs les jouets eux-mêmes à quatre
mois donc il puisse un jour protéger
leurs pions échanger leur fou parfois
trois c'est un à trois pour changer le
fou de cases noires à food endroits où
c'est un fou à trois reprises dans la
tour s'il y avait le pian anaqua si on
avait mis puis on a quatre triplés c'est
compliqué alors la manoeuvre donc c'est
pour ça que les dongeois 4 est aussi
sacs les noirs en jouer à quatre et on
disait aux six puits ont d'ailleurs on
voit lui dire voilà circle obtient on ne
peut plus protégé par son collègue
oui donc un coup ici de en fait on
bloque cette case en fait 5 ou de
blocage et en espère
un jour cet tirer profit du mauvais
foule de cases noires des joueurs du
joueur des blancs alors l'idée aussi
pour les blancs on va peut-être être
plus tard de jouer 5 toujours le est
menacée il faut prendre en cavalier
toujours le coup et cinq qui l attaquent
thématique de chêne toujours cette idée
un permanente
alors faut 3 on peut d'abord on peut
viser effectivement lecavalier 6 à terme
et on peut aussi jouer fou c'est un s'il
le faut c'est de porter d'ici
voilà ça y est il a joué il a joué 5
mais jouer cinq là quand même
oh là là peut prendre avec les noirs on
peut prendre mais il y aura à foug prend
un intermédiaire manger 4 et si le fou
prend g7 on prend le cavalier oui et on
se retrouve avec une égalité
maxime hâtive avec avec le pied en cap 7
qui sera assez pour arriérés il y aura
une compensation pour 1
il faut il faut stimuler ficta donc ils
préfèrent voilà on peut faire enlever le
cavalier pâle et calculer ça qu'en
moyenne ne joue pas cette variante
fallait calculer ça alors on pourrait
jouer mais cleveland cavaliers j'ai cinq
attaquants h cet ep cette force en
quasiment la prise il le fait mais le
fait oui pour pour forcer il veut jouer
fou contre cavaliers la finale
oui oui il veut avoir un déséquilibre de
pièces mineurs à noter que le four je
saigne dominera le cavalier de 8,1 oui
mais bon c'est pas facile
pas facile regarde le fou restera quand
même
mais pas sûr s'ils dominent ce cavalier
le forez ce train justement une
peut-être il va rendre se fout pas si
mauvais que ça il faut prendre il faut
prendre alors pourquoi ils dominent
parce que il prend toutes les cases du
cavalier voiliers et si les noirs jouer
mais noircissent il s'enlève une classe
folle cavale et qui est le coulis peut
venir 1 h 4 continue à contrôler les
cases du cavalier et donc ce foot voilà
il le fait vivre
il faut h80 jouent à chat alors il peut
jouer fou h4 c'est un train de dire ou
alors éventuellement pousser voilà
conviés au verre là il préfère regarder
le fou et garder cette candide le
fouillis vent qui peut passer devant la
chaîne alors un des principes quand on a
un mauvais fou c'est à dire dans subi
une chaîne fixé sur sa couleur c'est que
on essaie de passer le foule devant la
chaîne
j'aime pas trop dernier coup la dheune
benita puisqu'il a ouvert la colonne g
et voilà tout de suite
alors ça y est hyper duel déséquilibré
est vraiment en la faveur des blancs
alors là c'est une erreur de prendre un
f5 doute un coup comme ça alors la tour
prends c'est horrible oh là là trois
premiers sets le fonds local est attaqué
il faut que jouer qu'à les ossètes et il
va faire [ __ ] en chine ça y est c'est
fini
l'alberta david reprend l'avantagé dans
ce match là est décidément il a fait une
grosse grille et nous sommes bénis
talent en ouvrant sa position il n'était
pas obligé
alors quelle erreur ce qu'il faut voir
c'est à l'erreur les pièces de minutes
12 contre 10 minutes 08
attention aux renault ça compte le temps
qu il est temps que la position sur
l'échiquier avec pièce blanche son
supérieur en force aux pièces noires
elle n'est pas en a marre du fait qu'ils
aient le pion supplément mais la fuite
semble un peu fou
mortelle qu'est ce qui se passe là il y
aura un point 8 points 8
c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs peut-être
tour gsm à 8
peut-être aussi ce peut-être pas aussi
ce n'est peut-être pas aussi parce que
le pion s'affaiblit en avançant sur 23
de soutien donc ici pour simplement des
tourets fait retirer la tour retirer la
tour aussi s'il le fait ce qui signifie
aussi simple et aussi c'est au tour tout
aussi c'est étonnant mais il jouera
touré fama la smat
par exemple il prend emprise du 6 avec
échec il y aura pas mal je participe à
une erreur le coup aussi cela
bizarrement oui moi je n'étais pas
favorable à cette cruelle si ça ça va
vite mais surtout rejet 6 il ya tout
simplement tous réfutent matin hayatou
riz finale messieurs y avait match
puisque d'après lui enlever donc c'est
pour ça qu'il a pu jouer aussi c'était
pour la tourbe et s'épaulent assez
horrible et le lent que les blancs sont
archi gaye est donc maintenant j'essaye
menaces et menaces manas maaf e-menaces
maths et là il faut jouer tour à venir
c'est le gard où le bien c'est simple ou
h4 est sûre cavaliers prend pour un
chien et le cavaly clouer le cavaliere
serait que la torah suite oh la la c'est
horrible ça y est c'est foutu que veut
dire fils et moi sommes bénis talent au
niveau du temps aussi il est très mal
puisqu'il reste que 30 se respecte il va
perdre la tour alberto david va enfin
prendre la saillie sur wade 8 qui aura
courageux suite tous âges s'étaient
c'est fini c'est fini voilà ça y est
c'est terminé
avantage vient de remporter alberto
david oui et benita n'avait pas dans ce
match quand il veut mais en vain
dans la prochaine partie pour équilibrer
et jouer la mort voilà le temps de
remettre terminer une commande belle
belle leçon
donc on voit que là que le temps en plus
joue beaucoup en 2012 contre 25 secondes
avec une position pareille venant s'est
perdu à toi je suis doit être perdus sur
wade 8 évidemment on joue le coût total
cet échec avec le fou et la tourache
huit tombes
il a eu des difficultés benita valoriser
sa sa structure de deux pions voilà
alors que pièces se sont remises en
place pour la dernière partie de ce
match benita johan vainqueur de l'open
de logettes l'an dernier va devoir
maintenant à égaliser gagner dans ces
blitz de départage il faut qu'ils
gagnent face à artix au grand maître
international
alberto à david pour espérer jouer le
blitz mort subite qui lui permettrait de
passer en demi finale de ce grand prix
des chèques de bordeaux demi finales qui
auront lieu demain à partir de 15h pour
la première demi-finale et 17 heures
pour la deuxième demi finale match tendu
ça va être quand même tendu dans la tête
des joueurs ainsi que c'est pas évident
de jouer un match comme ça en partie
rapide coup de fouet au cab et le casque
sur les oreilles
c'est vrai qu'on les met à rude épreuve
vous disputez donc avantage à david
nous accueillons parti tel match très
bon match un seul agent très finalement
un finaliste match de démarrage mais de
belles nul très tendue des nuls disputé
disputé ici au théâtre fémina dans
d'excellentes conditions pour regarder
un match de haut niveau
voilà des quatre cas les psy ces quatre
jessica laissé trois fous g7 que quatre
des six ça y est voilà c'est là là c'est
la même partie que la première la mc
nish voilà donc on voit que les joueurs
sont préparés parce que ils rejouent
exactement jouent leur système leur
système comme finalement aucun des
joueurs n'a pris avantage
enfin signe qu'ils avaient pris en otage
finalement dans celle là s'il y avait eu
un avantage que ça y est cette fois il
fait quand reconquis varie parallèle à
ces progrès sinon voilà il est ce pas le
on est joué forcément ça parte voilà
exactement et il avait fini par prendre
l'aventage l'yonne bitam et à la fin
suite à une erreur de l'alberta david
qui s'amenait et sortent là il va subir
la gca drôle à la peur ah oui mais bien
sûr il joue son va tout voilà les yeux
nous avons donc
les fameuses parties a reproposé camp
rock
chez alcan et petit rock dans notre
coeur peut trouver dans notre camp
prison g4 évidemment c'est le coup
logique
puis on prend bessin voilà dans ses
dents tout c'est que ces matchs de rock
opposé c'est une question de course le
pion mari vont vous prendre cavaliers
évidemment lors l'idée de foot franck
cavallier
c'est sans doute de jouer le courage
c'est absolument ouvrir la colonne a
juste heureuse dans la suite
dans ce type de partie ce sens des
partis alors que fondane works sur fou
prend les noirs peuvent se heurter à
cavaler des cinq qui semble jouable rien
faut prendre là encore peut-être câbles
et des synchros non f4 au dollar ces
colis des questions de course à on veut
jouer le synphot tellement avant
d'enterrer live earth est souvent
enterré le fou de cases noires qui me
joins aux cinq qui est une arme
redoutable parce que ils attaquent b2
ils visaient les gaz chauds du roi blanc
de jouer f4 alors lieu delta joue pour
le gain c'est pour ça qu'ils jouent à
extrêmement agressif attention h5 est
possible même si j'ai 5 et la réponse
prévue sans doute par les noirs puisque
regarder h s'est vraiment montré la
variante h5 gsm et si les blancs près
d'angers saint leusiens il y aura fou
prend il y aura fou prend avec un
clouage d'am-dam rend très agréable
malgré qu avec la wii la wii la profite
pleinement been qu'il a joué au cices
donc ça c'est intéressant le système
quand même un d'alberto david contre
l'as amish
oui il faut que le
il joue aussi ce pour empêcher calais
des 5 il a compris la leçon de la
première partie donc cavalier b1 cavale
et b1 et là on voit que le pion à deux
va avoir des problèmes et que la même
combinaison tour à 8 pour prendre à deux
peut-être être possible pour les noirs
attention attention la cavale et bien
maintenant la menace des blancs c'est
sans doute de prendre angers 6 pour
ouvrir la colonne h
les blancs ont des atouts aussi il ya
des atouts ya des atouts est ce que les
noirs vont jouer gsm pour bloquer cette
cette avancée c'est possible
intéressante est possible très très
possible ou intéressant c'est un coup
intéressant j'ai c'est possible mais on
n'a pas trop envie et non de laisser
cette colonne s'ouvrir c'est mais il le
fait bon il le fait le fait donc il s en
fout jl sète ils tolèrent l'ouverture de
tolère où il s est même fait rage 6
éventuellement mais là j'y serai pas un
bon coup ce qu'on reviendra m6 voilà et
achète on jouera à chuter le roi est
tranquille en fait c'est le pion qui le
protège voilà le pian servirait le
parapluie au roi noir - de parachute
donc à l'époque des parachutes donc
parachute doré tout ça ah je prends
merci danger si ce qui comprend la tour
maintenant et puissante
voilà tout puissante mais c'est vrai
qu'avec un fou g7 qui déforme bon mais
c'est très difficile d'attaquer le roi
quand même parce que la même année
imaginons que la dame arrive en rage 2
et 11 7 rebonds leroy toujours une porte
de sortie en aide cette donc pour pour
mater il faudrait que dans ce cas la
cavalière j'espère un cavalier se met
ici pour fit pour bloquer ce qu'on
appelle le cercueil mai
1 pour bloquer le cercueil bio alors
j'ai cinq empêché de sortir le garder
dans la boîte des trois de la part des
noirs alors même thème le noir veut
absolument ouvrir une colonne sur le roi
où il veut ouvrir les colonnes sur la
toile et non pas le choix de leur faut
prendre un il n'y a pas le choix donc b3
les blancs vont prendre
il est sûr d'ouvrir la colonne même si
dans la référente tout de suite pour
l'accabler b4y les superbes ce cavalier
fantastique gabarit très puissant il
bloque les pions peut faire des échecs
on a deux et il il intervient il est
puissant près du roi blanc très puissant
non le fou c'est 8 va pouvoir peut-être
sortir en a6 aussi pourquoi pas oui faut
peut-être fois ci ce donc là il ya deux
échecs la 2e db sur la nul suffit
alberto david mais bien sûr faut pas
oublier qu alberto david a gagné la
première partie
donc s'il trouve une oeuvre qui la
mâchoire johan benita il faut qu'ils
jouent à 2,3 euros à 7,3 c'est sûr qu'à
l'échec il faut qu'ils viennent en d3
mais voilà c'est horrible c'est horrible
là haut le dernier coup là d'alberto il
vous suffit de jouer fois six annoncées
sur la seule race effectuer ces
ouvertures de ces foutus puisque le fou
g7 qu'attaquant la scierie b pas
accepter la louisiane benita devait
jouer pour le ghana ne pouvait pas
accepter l'annulant de là on voit
vraiment la force du fou g7 est indien
et puis mon intérêt oui oui le mener au
score surtout ils ont mené au score
crois que là même la considération la
position est moins important que le
score dans qui prend des cadres là c'est
horrible ce qui arriva c'est vraiment
horrible ce qui arrive à yoann benita
sayyed à la parole à la loi maintenant
il ya la table regarder la table 1 qui
menace
un échec à la découverte du cavalier
attaquant ici le roi la dame
le chasseur devient chasser rôle alors
là c'est horrible c'est lui c'est foutu
c'est foutu pays tu as moins d'un
miracle a glissé le matériau rigide à
mach 4 il veut c'est de le mater mais
peut-être que peut-être qu'alberto à une
combinaison de nuls ce qui serait
horrible commis les ondes nul je me
demande si cavaliers detroit échec est
pas mal et des trois régates usa ouais
ouais non c'est pas un gain ce serait
match puisque sur roy prend il y aurait
fou à six matches mais non il y aurait
encore leroy qui part sur la colonne
s'aimer et on ne donne pas les animaux
ainsi en c2 oui ça m'aide à dépenser 1
mais après tout c'est une série de
lecavalier serait plus là mais je pense
que ça vaut car il ya d'assez haut
rhinois joue cavalier à 2 le port
yéménite a condamné avoir la même
position sans donner le cavalier alors
au lieu de me proposer nul
évidemment mais ça serait signé la fin
du match évidemment le match compte plus
que la partie oui c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre une avancée essentielle en
cette douce au dernier blitz de savoir
que la alberto david mène au score et
que young benita n'avait pas le choix
que de jouer l'horrible loi c-32 jouer
l'horrible roi c3 que maintenant là
c'est une minute 26 points mérités
contre minutes 30 avant tout la vie d'un
certain stress adam se qualifier pour
les demi finales de ce septième grand
prix l'échec de bordeaux et sa vie avec
les toutes les lignes sera assez
horrible c'est vraiment horrible ce qui
se passe pour la cavale et prend il peut
faire un échec mais comme on l'a vu tout
à l'heure au roi f7 elle habite les
pièces sa menace encore tous en fuite
qui ramassera la tourache 1 pour les
noirs ce serait des pièces blanches ne
sent pas assez coordonnés pour leur
attaque a que deux pièces je crois qu'il
ne peut rien faire la menace évidemment
c'est qu'avec prendre bien avec échec de
la dame et là c'est fini voilà c'est
terminé
victoire victoire du grand maître sur le
m il ya monsieur alberto david a
remporté ce deuxième blitz et donc
remporte le départage 2 à 0 monsieur
benita s'est bien battu mais cette fois
il est tombé sur le plus fort que lui
donc le vainqueur
monsieur alberto david merci patrick
donc c'était un match très tendu très
dynamique très très intéressant je crois
qu'il ya eu il ya eu des fautes de part
et d'autre on pénètre alberto simplement
on a collé de jouer assez tendue c'est
vrai que j'ai eu l'impression qu'on a
fait des choses il est encore difficile
peut-être pas commenter à chaud je ne
l'exclus un peu embrouillé à cause de
lui que c'était un peu compliqué alors
on a l'impression johan si je me
rappelle bien dans le bon ce deuxième
but s'il n'y avait pas le choix
en fait comme tu devais gagner ce
deuxième blitz tu as dû jouer le rouleau
ribes leroy c3 et parce que sinon elle
perd tout menacé de faire nul en fait
c'était un peu dur alors on a
l'impression dans le 1er bis perdu que
tu aurais raté le coup cavale et prend
un f5 parce que c'est ce que c'est le
cas de carey price saint-cloud t'as pas
vu que la dame peut-être f6 attaqué la
dame b si c'est parce que tu te
rappelles de la position est bien et
d'ailleurs c'est moi qui ai mal
et quand j'ai échangé les dames je
pensais que c'était fini en fait il a eu
beaucoup de contres jeu et j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance qu après ce match nul
finalement c'est ça voilà finalement une
nouvelle je confonds avec il a trouvé
plein de ressources tactique en milieu
de jeu que j'avais pas vu avec des
sacrifices dans tous les sens en tout
cas on vous remercie tout le monde je
crois que c'était un très très bon match
à suivre très tendu voilà merci ils
plaisent autant dire merci à vous et
donc à bien de toi voilà merci
et donc voilà c'est terminé pour ce pour
ce premier match du grand prix de
bordeaux et rendez vous bien à 17h pour
le match entre laurent frayssinet et le
champion d'aquitaine 2005 - merci
[Musique]
non